tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo nuovo
video sono fa vj oggi domenica e quindi
siamo su è prevista la prima puntata
estiva di epico il sistema roba tipo
summer neo su domino è un casino di voi
mi hanno sito ma favi ma continui a fare
più visto anche se la puntata 64 se
assolutamente se parte che mi sfogo è un
casino e poi voglio arrivare alla 100
voglio arrivare a quella cazzo di 100
press the boat behind baia e di puoi
fare forza follower del dominus e non
faccio un cazzo ci fa tutto lui ma se io
rimanevo a sorte prendo la palla tocca
gata come cosa è successo non lo capiva
bene non importa è stata un'esperienza
beh sì ma io non faccio un cazzo rigato
non lo faccio un cazzo mio no io non fa
niente inizierà a prendere il soffitto a
che bella i miei esercizi di stretching
è una gara tra me il domino ragazzi
siete scrivere prima io al traguardo si
arriva fino al domino mai ma che è dura
e non so chi cazzo non ci credo spingi
ma che vince lui spinge avanti lurido
lanci credo è di vero 6
ma per favore guarda che la macchinina
va più veloce di te ma renditi conto se
younis vai vai tu non c'è verso ora è
bravissimo se riuscissi a prendere di
nuovo il coso prendi lo so se ce l'ho
fatta perfetto è stata la cosa più
tragica della storia mai vedere un
vecchio che cercava di scappare
va beh rob e tristi segui live rpg a
questo è un summer vai così fight of
human to get by her to fight mi senti
steve non rompermi i [ __ ] infatti un
giro ti prego ascolta fratello ma sti
cazzi che forza che si è mangiato
spinaci o droghe ti sei in pompato zio
cosa è successo file e fortissimo cioè
impossibile la posso fare ragazzi ce la
posso fare per grifondoro è bravo bravo
ed i primi inchiosto ragazzo mi dà
soddisfazione jump to enter beolink
amava dire le sue cose ma che ne so
niente devo fare prima allenamento e poi
posso prenderlo ma serio ed hi fi
allenamento fi allenamento più forza più
forza
l'accordo ragazzi mi sono pompato
abbastanza sono diventato un appello del
sì come stai
senti ho fatto poi che tiene un salto in
palestra attiva di provare a fare un
combattimento giusto così pam cioè il
cairo zio vieni qua fratello vieni che
non ti faccio niente via hobbs sei morto
centri stesso combattimento più trash
della è no però non li ho spaccato
neanche la testa è almeno quello harvard
university adesso posso aumentare la mia
intelligenza entrato anche steve
ecco un altro cervello non può entrare
non sei abbastanza in grado zio line più
intelligenza anche qui li mortacci sua
che dovevo fare al massimo ciarcià fe
primis la chiesa di happy meals questa
non la vorrei vedere mai nella vita però
proviamoci a non ti fanno entrare o
armeno my son contento avanti webcam
cosa stava lavorando nei
[Musica]
i big money con la cassa bellissimo io
uno più uno più uno che sai dai che
diventi bill gates general store act
meno 5 posso comprare un cappello nonno
dammi il cappello immediata me lo voglio
subito da jano mi ha [ __ ] 5 dollari
sto bastardo
ho perso il mio cappello ma come noi
cappello me lo terrei io l'ho pagato a
brighton dello stesso sei troppo swag
zio fattelo dire poi di avere questa
moneta grazie molto gentile ma finirà
maisto livello ci siamo ragazzi devo
prendere la towel dal nigger è una roba
tipo ho preso ho vinto stata la cosa più
trash che io abbia mai giocato in tutta
la mia vita ma va bene è il tizio è
sempre comunque troppo slide land anche
epic 3.3.0 e la madonna cos'è ma diamoci
un bel 9 è una roba così ho preso bravo
completa è così che si fa canestro e
vinto tutto è uno sport questo stare
sulla palla con le ginocchia
mi piace e bellezza ecco la madonna
questa invece era da 10
ho fatto guai roba c'è mica steve e la
palla si sono ritrovati un fenomeno
si no ciò che l'epa che ho dato lo
vedesse madonna mica che minaccia estive
per favore no non limon arti con
l'avversario non limone non toccarli
capezzoli non serve a niente
allora senti zio devi ascoltarmi la devi
smettere di limonare come ok ti devi
togliere dalle palle bravo succhiate le
[Musica]
robe 9 a caso cosa ho fatto voglio il
replay subito c'è vabbè vabbè regga il
canestro più epico della storia di
qualsiasi storia e non ho mai vista una
roba così fretta attacca l'attacco degli
obesi easy so già morto è la madonna
sono benzema sono cazzuti cioè non è che
brava beta è riuscita a questo più
difficile ma perché degli open si
dovrebbero attaccarmi cosa ci hanno
rotto di me perché son macro e non è
colpa mia se sono macro e sex cosa vuoi
tu che ci hai vestito hawaiano cosa vuoi
cosa vuoi assaggia la mia ruota line per
voi cos'è
devo fare il cecchino ma cosa ma luke ma
come te che ti ha insegnato forse cose
non tuo padre ma con allora senti zio
spara non sparate non sparate di uk non
sei spa un po prima e magari la prossima
volta ci siamo ragazzi stavolta ci siamo
e questo mi sa che è morto credo è non
ne sono sicuro che lavora ancora in
un'agorà una forza madonna ciogli e 18
nel corpo rega sono la potenza europa
non è bellissimo perché mica fa saltare
in aria qualsiasi cosa
un altra roba ancora una mio padre è
vabbè il papa è sempre papà boom mi
chiama io non è un fucile da cecchino
questo un cannone cosa fa
ma cos'è ma cos'era
[Musica]
c'è la gara era il mio [ __ ] vedi dopo
quello cioè che lo dico eccolo eccolo
perfetto abbiamo chiuso ragazzi abbiamo
fatti tutti perfetti sono un killer
ormai sono un chilo sono un bambino ma
soso sparare quindi attenti a non
portarmi i giocatori giusti in crash
uno schianto aereo ma come oddio mamma
no penso di essere elli dio mio sono
vivo ancora vivo sono vivo lurida
macchina di merda c'è di te mi pare una
persona che cade da un aereo è morta
come schiacciata da una macchina come
com'è possibile
e difficilissimo sopravvivere a star o
basse pedana ti uccido riuscire mi scusi
signora non volevo guardarle la budria è
solo che ecco grazie e buon viaggio
la mia testa è partita ma [ __ ] è
una roba indecente fosse impossibile è
di non sai guidare evita ragazzi ho un
ginocchio nella spalla non so come sia
possibile ragazza diventa devo
sopravvivere maine e soprattutto sentite
ieri il padre di uk vieni salvami va beh
almeno siamo morti entrambi perfetto ai
dai dai dai dai dai
sì sì già fatta allora c'è mica se mi
chiede qualcosa in testa m'incazzo ho
vinto cielo fattore che è stato è stato
tragico però se volete sopravvivere uno
schianto è spuntato un pene nero e
grosso se volete sopravvivere uno
schianto di aereo questo è l'unico modo
l'unico skateboard kid
ok allora sì no no cos'è cos'è cos'è
questa cosa la gamma dio mio cielo
allora sentiti io non so che personaggi
di happy sia questo ma il mio preferito
in assoluto lo voglio ma lo skateboard
ultrasonico sta cosa ma sei serio
e stato il livello più bello che io
abbia mai giocato da da quando gioco è
più solo che è già finito peccato perché
era un figo il tizio dai ragazzi pro i
primi i primissimi livelli che avevate
fatto per me tipo secoli fa per farvi
jazz che si sono anno tipo 20mila anni
se non sono anche non ero neanche nato
io non andare indietro per pendolari e
io cosa farò mai ti conosco benissimo
grazie zia non so non sono cambiato
negli anni sono sempre più stupido
fatemi solo cadere di sotto perfetto
grazie no io un po stronzo è questo
ragazzi comunque è un nuovo tipo di
altalena che serve per sgranchire bene
le ossa la mattina lo brevettiamo poi fa
vj non può farlo cosa sei serio
zio non mi conosce anche to miss a te lo
dico ok prova l'ultima fa vj e il suo
mito
i nostri cinema televisione livelli
indicati per lui si fa vj o un topo sono
un topo zio che cazzo vuol dire questa
cosa va beh ok ma no dai forse ce la
faccio ancora senza niente perché sei
pregando su una freccia zio che abbiamo
provato ragazzi non è così semplice come
sembra
usa la sla non ho letto un cazzo non
importa a me non importa se no io sono
forte anche così senza saper niente tiro
le frecce sono partito a canzo
vabbè dai vediamo se riesco ad atterrare
sul traguardo impossibile ci ho sperato
[ __ ] d'accordo ragazzi conclude
l'episodio è stato strano veramente
ottimamente happy è strano no a me non è
che sia stato mai norma ti ammazzo 2 3 2
1 3 1 2
ok ragazzi con quello viene episodio
spero che le video vi sia piaciuto è
stato rinfrescante buona domenica 6 dove
piaciuto ma se dal suo commento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook e comunali
video trovata una descrizione sono
sempre stati stilati ci vediamo non
possimo delle ragazze